à 107 ans cette femme de la communauté
indigène a reçu une dose de vaccin ce
mercredi le brésil a commencé à vacciner
massivement sa population dans la
banlieue de sao paulo
les villageois voit l'arrivée du sérum
d'un très bon oeil nous sommes très
heureux de faire partie des premières
personnes à se faire vacciner ici dans
l'état de sao paulo et dans notre
communauté qui est une très grande
population
la vaccination a aussi débuté à manaus
capitale de l'état d'amazonas dont le
système sanitaire est à la limite de
l'effondrement selon le ministre de la
santé brésilien l'apparition d'un
nouveau variant a provoqué une flambée
épidémique dans cette ville située en
plein milieu de la forêt amazonienne
l'arrivée des vaccins apporte donc une
lueur d'espoir
notre lutte est une question de vie ou
de mort
nos efforts visent à sauver des vies
plus nous y parviendrons
plus les gens seront sauvés et nous
pourrons y parvenir si nous sommes unis
que dieu nous bénisse tous merci
il y a quelques jours ces images de
manaus avait fait le tour du monde
les hôpitaux étant saturés les
brésiliens faisait la queue pour
récupérer de l'oxygène et ainsi aider
leurs proches en insuffisance
respiratoire à cause du kof 19 mardi
le venezuela est venu à la rescousse de
cette ville coupée du reste du brésil
plusieurs cas nous vénézuéliens ont
apporté 132 1000 litres d'oxygène pour
approvisionner la ville de plus de deux
millions d'habitants
recevoir cette charge d'oxygène du
venezuela pour la ville de manaus est
très important pour équilibrer
l'approvisionnement en oxygène au réseau
de santé public d'amazonas
nous traversons une période difficile en
matière d'approvisionnement et toute
aide toute donation que nous recevons
est la bienvenue en particulier cette
grosse donation qui vient du venezuela
nous remercions le peuple vénézuélien de
l'affection qu'il porte à la ville de
manaus dans l'état d'amazonas et lui
adressons nos plus sincères
remerciements et notre gratitude pour le
soutien qu'ils nous apportent lundi le
brésil a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination au pied du christ rédempteur
de rio de janeiro un acte symbolique
dans un des pays les plus meurtries par
le cos vite 19 avec plus de deux cent
onze mille morts depuis le début de la
pandémie
le brésil est le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde derrière les etats
unis